you don't need me to point out this
study that Associated excess of screen
time to poor performance on
developmental screening tests you don't
need me to point out this article
suggesting that too much screen time
leads to obesity and sleep issues if
you're part of the Coco melon generation
chances are that Coco really is messing
with your mojo now I should be fair and
say that some of the research I found
actually discovered an increased
attention span for kids who use the iPad
they were better at blocking out
distractions the key seems to be using
it in moderation so screens aren't bad
but too much screen time can be harmful
which is exactly what Katie is talking
about here and Gemma is is disregarding
we'll revisit this